guys we're here at London Film comes
today who are you I am red mist and I am
kick-ass
I need a foursome both a now what is it
about redness and kick-ass it is so
appealing well they're homemade
superheroes so we don't need any
superpowers or we don't need to like
have any special abilities we just need
to look cool and be able to dance so we
just dancing around sure spit at the
dancing thank God
I gotta tell you I'm living it now
kick-ass why do you think oh this is an
average guy he's kinda like Peter Parker
he just wants to do good and you know
he's got good morals kind of like
Leonardo it was like Leonardo from the
turtles he was righteous like Captain
America just stand up for the you know
the innocent and kick the bad guy's ass
now are you guys fans of the comic books
yeah I'm a huge mark millar fan and
makes a big fan of the kick-ass comic so
yeah we love comics and I'm toys what is
it about the kick-ass comic that we
really love it's very brutal and it's
very honest and it's very hard in
because the second one I can't wait for
the movie to come out and yeah what is
it about the guys you play kick-ass and
red mist on screen that you like
well obviously everyone loves McLovin
and so that's fun to do like kick ass
because he said British film like made
him in Britain totally British but then
Americans can think was made in America
which it wasn't so I always like guard
as well great hit girl let's go that you
think she's growing up to be a beautiful
woman
like when I first watch it I was like
well that's a bit wrong but like
watching him now so she's getting a bit
older it's getting okay
Oh guys what did you enjoy about the
first clicker to move it I just think
how funny it was like a fresh kind of
humor to superhero films I thought Nic
Cage is awesome and it was Nick Cage
back on form so yeah it's all good what
would you like to see happen for your
characters in the new movie well I've
changed my name to the mother word and
so that's going to be interesting and
they shouldn't have a bigger part I did
more of the same light if they doing
exactly like the first one and don't
don't sell out like I think it'll be
great thing to be a really good film
what's it like today well I don't give
anyways spoilers but my dad dies so
that's gonna be heartbreaking for me but
again I just can't wait to see it it's
gonna be amazing
now guys tell me a little bit about
these outfits are you go on today get
your looking mighty cool both eh well we
came here last year and we were Cyclops
and Wolverine and so oh my god his
kick-ass costume so it was either Big
Daddy or redness and I thought redness
was cooler so but this is real - yeah
like I buy the costume and then I have
the worst clubs ever so like last last
year with my Wolverine costume I had
marigolds because I couldn't find any
more in gloves so it's a running joke
now that I have an awesome costume but
terrible gloves
it's good the terrible grip the grip I
think I got a good grip I like the way
you got your mobile phone in that
leather but no pockets you want to feel
my wallet this I'm not just pleased to
see you guys you're looking very cool
how much you enjoying it's our Christmas
stage because we get to meet we have
like three Christmases we got to meet
all our celebrities let me go alone and
shop and have a good time shopping
yeah this is our third part of our
Christmas so we're just having the best
day ever this is this is our Christmas
earlier for one day which from Wales so
traveling down early in the morning it's
like I got it for like 22 for I can go
back to bed I was that excited like oh
my god
he's really out there with you this year
Christmas
yes Christmas kids guys enjoy the rest
of your day hear you're looking for show
everybody want to taking your photos and
talking to you have a fabulous time
you